le chocolat pour moi c'est quelque chose
qui était menacé
c'est très rigide ça demande beaucoup de
discipline
puis je pense que ça me convient
moi je vois c'est beaucoup comme un
travail d'artisan en fait il ya aussi
tout un côté technique qu'il faut
respecter qui est vraiment important
les gens s'intéressent un peu plus aux
origines du chocolat d'où viennent-ils
tailles de tous est de plus en plus en
plus informés que ça c'est le soin
c'est ma mère qui ne vous est toujours
un petit peu avec autant de
découragement que d'enthousiasmé les
chacals andré c'est comme une secte
parce que on a toujours fait nos
chocolats nous crie au caramel de la
même façon avant que je voudrais que ce
qui est très très populaire c'est les
yeux à la crème au beurre définitivement
c'est un classique
depuis plusieurs années les
le chocolat noir est toujours très
populaire